hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to among the sleep now
we are picking up where we left off
before which is we got the star piece
and we anchored some demon in the
kitchen very much so he did not like us
singing his star but I don't think he
has much room to complain he's just
gonna have to suck it up and get over it
because we oh my gosh why is that person
why is that chicken man leaning over
that person and why are they crying but
these are all drawings provided by this
little kid because I have an idea that
this kid is a little bit disturbed but
maybe not for his own reasons that's a
guy with big club okay that's a guy with
big club like arms looming over that
little tiny itty bitty man which
probably means that somebody is gonna be
looming over me with their big meaty
arms okay someone sad and someone's in a
box over there what does that mean what
does it all mean where the hell am I
going and how do I get back again it is
a thing it is si okay I panicked I'm
gonna fess up I'm gonna be the bigger
man and I'm gonna say that I panicked
it's okay anybody could have done that I
thought I was gonna die bah ah this is
an area of forgiving so we're gonna
pretend like that never happened he
wasn't gonna kill me but he probably is
in the future which is now because the
future is now and death isn't coming why
is this set up to make me make noise why
do you want me to knock over boxes and
bottles cuz I'm not gonna no way nohow
what would happen if I did
oh no good okay oh my goodness
finally man you finally have a coat on I
was wondering what offer for you her an
[ __ ] I didn't expect anything to
actually happen out of that oh my god
huh I honestly did not expect something
to actually happen I'll just go on not
disturbing anything anymore
very carefully navigating the area would
you see keys I make noise of will leave
the doors open wave is a little really
clever dude gonna like this very much
when I supposed to touch anything
if I touch even as I can take will he
come after me who I could go with those
what is that
where's the chair being lit who's the
chair being with only the chair is that
the Buddy Rich here those the most
pathetic squeak I've ever heard is it
the little kid screaming is that it that
all you got
ah come on I was expecting more than
actually that was pretty awesome that
was very entertaining thank you for that
the comedic relief of that chair how
many of you guys are scared by the chair
tell me God be honest here how many get
scared
oh you know who you are okay anyway
that's carry-on hey sky into scary now
that I know that there's adorable chairs
squeaking at me there's no what
I'm sorry okay no noise waking you here
was my bow that was dope what's going on
over there who's talking about Oh
somebody want to say something to me
somebody want to explain this situation
to me yeah I don't see anybody I don't
see anybody all this bad ah my god my
wookie
we're oke we just do a test here dude
another thing ah I knew anymore huh
looks like he's all bark and no bite
ain't gonna bother me no more he knows
I'm far too Manolis to be bothered by
the legs of him huh what a loser
well Laser only comes out once a game to
be creepy for two seconds and then do
nothing about it
whoa loser okay so I gotta get across
that gap somehow goddamnit I'm gonna
fall I'm gonna go through the wall of T
of giant coats there are all definitely
not monsters definitely not masters but
now there is a co wearing monster that I
need to be wary other what is that was
that there's a picture of people with
their faces scratching who is that
that meteors enemies that Mir is one of
those me oh no way one of those me
they're older than I am are they're
older than my kid self is okay good good
we made it across does this mean we're
getting out okay oh god there's an
earthquake going on right now
well not goodness the ground is shaking
either that or the man is staying right
well
and he's about to kill me I don't know
which is true well why did that turn red
I don't know but I got the thing is it
good what do I do now
okay key so I'm gonna happen as soon as
I drop down cuz I think that's what's
gonna happen nobody okay houki
hey good we're all friends here we're
all friends good okay i won
I want to see no okay and is he dumpy is
he gonna go elephants all over the place
and kill everybody in town cuz that's
what don't be did this seems almost too
easy
who's the man in the overcoat we got
vinyl memory
yes it's due wait where am I going
wait what do you need me to do I thought
it automatically gave me a pipe where's
the pipe where's the pipe the pipe in
here is the pipe in here does it look
like where the vibe is totally know
where the pipe is okay well I'm just
gonna pop in each of these rooms just to
make sure that I'm not missing anything
because I know you guys would be very
miffed if I didn't check it oh that's
the opposite of chuffed this just which
is the prison of happy and then there's
miffed which means not happy yah yah yah
yah yah yah we're in these things he's
got to be little secrets okay that guy's
not happy mm-hmm need hello can I get in
there no it does not look like okay yah
yah yah yah yah yah I'm coming mama
top there's a lot of rooms that I need
to check okay don't some in there mmm
about in there sorry okay
I made an error of god all them flew
open for me
I thought I was supposed to be very
patient and meticulous you weren't
supposed to kill me I'd be very clear I
was not suppose it disobey then okay
who's this go thread for it no worries
I'm running I'm running put away your
bear and run run run run kid don't fall
don't fall don't fall jump into thing
okay didn't realize there was a bit
there that was my bad Hey
yeah continue come on I need to get
through this now I'm just wasting time
and now I look like an idiot which is
something that I definitely not need to
do so just get through the door go
through jump through crawl like a baby
because apparently it's faster for some
reason go go go go go
this time get up because you need to
jump ups easily
oh god those my hand wasn't it the
through kids okay through no no no no
come on baby
Oh what oh God very
no anywhere oh no wait anywhere I
thought you were evil but were you okay
what's he actually good no I fell I fell
in that hole that I died in before oh no
no no okay
it's not a good thing Fuki follow the
light I play this game before and I
remember that I don't like it what are
those what are those those cheese
oh no that's fluff that's the fluff from
my teddy bear now well not now not now
what am I really a grown man in insane
asylum recalling his childhood
butoh veggetti but I'm actually very sad
about that
oh hi mama mama mama
mom and mama my mommy okay it's not
going well it's very not going well my
teddy bear might be dead
you got his arm enough I see
mama you've been drinking apparently I
didn't notice that before but hooky Oh
No
you're covered in red Wow oh god where
my stars going red
okay this is bad why could ask why I
don't like this hello ladies
I like other giving individuals shun
Sunshower you okay
do
huh am I supposed to do
are they just sending him a me you can't
do what mommy says
going to be very angry none of us want
that none of us there's more than just
two DUIs
okay
you didn't seem like this in the nods
psycho world you seem like a good loving
mother there's still some rumblies going
on here live from earthquake central is
this creepy cave actually I think the
atmosphere the game is penetrating the
real world so much that it's actually
affecting me so I need to put the last
memory in and then what then what if I
do what do I do
is it gonna be the finale hoodude oh
very curious excellent the teddy bear
how will I be able to push the button I
have his arm that's why okay
I remember now that is totally dumpy
that is definitely dumpy that's actually
the pink elephant that was hidden in the
first part of the game yeah come on okay
yay
okie dokie let's go cling clang BAM bang
now have the little arm that I will push
the button King I really have nothing
else to say I really have no idea what's
gonna happen so it's just going find out
cuz I I don't know who's maybe the
finale if not then you'll all cave is
definitely the finale I don't have my
teddy bear to guide me I don't have any
light I don't have anyone to comfort me
I'm all alone in the darkness you guys
are gonna cover me right wait a minute
is my closet the scenes on my wall my
darkness hey he did it I did it he did
it I did it her back am i back I don't
trust this for a gosh darn second
there's no way I'm back oh you're
looking much better mr. caterpillar man
ah okay there's that star okay there's
some moving boxes that I can't read
there's a puzzle piece Oh drugs us not
for one dingdong damn second there's the
hooters there's an empty bottle saw me
right here there's a key so uh some a
right okay
don't trust it not trusting it still not
trusting it hello mr. floppy bunny can
you be my friend can I hug you to my
chest
okay why is there a heartbeat going on
my ears
yeah something does seem very wrong
yeah I'll bet
hi what hi hello hmm hi
okay that's how good no
yes I never meant to okay okay it's
weird the hell's going on
hello god this is some heavy stuff
No
did you like your yet what happened to
czar don't move itself
holy crap
geez okay it's the end of the game oh
geez that was like the heaviest sending
I've ever seen it it didn't even involve
any death or anything it was just so sad
I've nothing to say vibe man seriously
III I can't even joke about that that
was like that was like seriously heavy
subject like the kid okay if you guys
don't get it I know a lot of you guys
probably do but God the kid was so like
disturbed from his mom being obviously
alcoholic and probably abusive in some
sort split in the beginning it didn't
even seem like that she seemed so
awesome and like the most loving mother
ever and I don't know what the hell is
happening that ending is so sad who to
go call my mom
goodness gracious alright so anyway that
game was up
I I don't mean to say that it was bad
but I mean that game was really good
that game was really solid all the way
through it was a bit shorter than I
would have hoped for but either way that
game my goodness huh it was terrifying
the ending just like hidden my heart so
hard than it hurts good I'm sorry for
anyone who's gone through that and got
reminded of like bad things happen in
their life but wowie Zowie
that was was rough all right either way
there's obviously a lot of backwards
user these credits are gonna take a
while to go through so I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna exit out to see if
there's anything else that's gonna be
happening and that looks like it so
either way that was among the sleep
thank you guys so much for watching this
game it is was an amazing playthrough I
haven't played a game to completion like
this that was this good in a long time
I really enjoyed it it was definitely
worth the wait they put a lot of work
into it I mean I wish it could have been
longer but it was
as long as it needed to be for the story
to get done and sometimes that's more
important oh my goodness there's still a
lot of unanswered questions there but
yeah
so either way hope you guys enjoyed this
playthrough hope you guys enjoyed me
commentating on and hope you found it
entertaining if you did please leave a
like down below check out some of my
other playthroughs there's a whole bunch
I'll put in the description for other
games you might enjoy that I played all
the way to the end so thanks again
everybody for watching I'll do another
one of these soon remember the RPG
horror game that you guys voted for is
also coming very soon so thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
pocket uh pastor he's already got a mark
in my book
Blackmore from not making the time I
came out there jiggly oh mooie-mooie